i was asked like is this your official
coming out and i was like
coming out from where i wasn't anywhere
to come out of
nisi nash is opening up about her
marriage to jessica betts
i never lived a sexually repressed life
i just love who i love when i love them
and
it's as simple as that the newlyweds sat
down with good morning america on
wednesday to talk about their romance
a romance that came as a surprise to
some since niecy had previously been
married
twice both times to men and just
finalized her divorce from jay tucker in
march
for us it's easy because we love each
other
the love is just taken on a different
form but that's always going to be my
friend
always but for the 50 year old actress
she says love is love and she found it
in jessica
it has nothing to do with gender or it
has
everything to do with being an amazing
person
and this is the most beautiful soul i
have ever met in my life
the two met over four years ago and
became quick friends
but the spark between them really
ignited when jessica appeared on
neesee's series clause in 2018.
i've been waiting for this day i knew it
was something the moment i met her
but um when i fell in love is when i
desired no one else
i knew as for nissi she said she always
felt connected to the 48 year old
but the romantic connection was fresh
the being in love is new but loving her
as a soul i've done that from the
beginning
oh and if all that wasn't sweet enough
on wednesday jessica dropped a new music
video for her single catch me
featuring her new wifey baby
catch me what it said to me was that is
what i'm looking for
that is the missing ingredient i
absolutely want somebody to see me
and that was when i knew i was fully in
love when i felt
fully seen and fully accepted probably
for the first time in my life
now the two are brainstorming other ways
to collaborate professionally
we are actually trying to find a place
where both of
our art intersects so we're working on
something like that right now
they also have a little advice for
anyone trying to live a more
authentic life when you live in your
truth
is when you're the most happy you are
right free
and free and it's nothing like that i
mean you know you can get caught up in
what other people think
if you want to but the main thing is
what you think and how you feel in your
being
and we feel so satisfied and so happy
and
we just you see it
[Music]